Now let's take a look at how we can go from something like this fairly robust breadboard
with nice cleaned up wires to something even more robust, something that we can implement,
say, in a robot that's moving around or on your bicycle or in a car or an industrial application
or something, or just the fact that you want to pass it around and let people play with this
prototype, right? These wires can get loose eventually, they corrode, they make misconnections,
it's just not the best long-term solution. So what we use is PerfBoard, and PerfBoard is perforated
board that you cut to whatever size you want, and you hardwire solder all those connections in place.
There's lots of different kind. This one is like a single point PerfBoard. Some of them have
rows that are all connected, similar to like a breadboard and how that's connected.
I like these, they're one-sided, and they have individual copper pads on each hole, and I'll show
you briefly how I would use it. This video is more about some tips and techniques more than actually
building something on a PerfBoard. It's fairly straightforward, but I've got some things that
should help you build it. Number one, size. Don't necessarily want this size of a PerfBoard.
I want something smaller. Maybe I'm creating a little board that breaks out all the analog pins
here of my Arduino. It'd be just so much easier to have a PerfBoard that could plug into there,
or have breakout header pins or something. So cutting it, cutting it. You can use little nippers,
you can use some scissors. Don't bother. I see lots of people doing that. You get jagged edges.
It's not the best way. Best thing you can do, go get some really cheap tin snips. Make sure you buy
whether you buy a right-handed or left-handed version. But look at this. If I were to take
this PerfBoard, or actually I have one here cut down already, and I were to just cut a row off of this,
I mean it cuts so easily. It leaves a nice clean edge, very little sharp corners. I mean it's just,
it's really nice. And if I wanted, say, a little breakout board from my Arduino, I can actually
just cut the board like that. And look at that. I've got this great little breakout board that I
could solder some header pins in and put it on my Arduino. Couldn't really be easier. So that's
number one, cutting. Number two, soldering. So if you're going to put a integrated circuit into your
board, you can solder it right to the PerfBoard, but trust me on this. And I've done it. Sadly,
I've done it. I still actually remember one time I was making an Arduino many, many years ago. I want
to say like close to 10 years ago. And I soldered my AT Mega, I don't remember, I think it was a 168
microcontroller in there. And I fried it. And once I soldered it in, I go to unsolder it. It was a mess.
It was horrible. Don't put your microcontrollers or integrated circuits, don't solder them directly to
a board. Use something like a socket. And this is a socket. And what this allows you to do is put it
into PerfBoard, solder this in from the backside. And then I can take my microcontroller and I can
snap it into the socket. Something happens, I can pop it out. If I change my code, I can actually have
on the side a couple of different microcontrollers with different codes. It's really great for demoing.
It's great for having a backup. So that's one thing. Another thing to know is when soldering to
the PerfBoard, and I'll grab my soldering iron real quick to show you. And you know what, I'm going to
make a quick note about this soldering iron. This is my used industrial grade MetCal soldering iron.
Why do I use this? This uses these RF tips. It's basically like a radio antenna, believe it or not,
that from my understanding excites the tip of the soldering iron and heats it up extremely fast. I love
this soldering iron. They're hundreds of dollars new, but you can go to eBay and buy them used for,
I think I paid under a hundred bucks for this. And what I like about it is if I go to turn it on,
I've just turned my soldering iron on.
And let these little brass there, let's see. There you go. It's already up to temperature.
I mean, what was that? A couple of seconds? Love it. It actually cools down just as fast.
But what I wanted to show you is let's say we were going to solder this header pin in here.
I push it through from this side.
And I can get in here and get a nice little blob of solder on my soldering iron.
I can tack it in place real quick.
And now that's tacked in place, right? But this is what I wanted to get at.
When working with PerfBoard, these are incredibly valuable.
This is a rosin flux pen. And what this does is it cleans and is a facilitator for the solder to flow.
So if I'm going to go in here, you can see the PerfBoards typically are a little,
I don't want to say messy, but they're not exactly the cleanest of all things.
And with a little flux pen, it makes soldering so much easier.
Trust me on this one. You want a pen
like this. This is a
rosin flux pen by
MG Chemicals. These are really
handy to have. They're also really good when you're reworking solder joints.
Paint over it with some of the flux
and you will desolder much easier.
So there's another tip. There I got my header pins in here.
Last but not least, I want to also mention that
if you are going to
solder a bunch of things together,
like let's say you needed a whole bunch of pins connected along a bar.
I've mentioned earlier in videos, I saved these little
clips from my LEDs and I'll usually have a few on hand.
These can be very handy when soldering on a PerfBoard.
Again, I can flux this
and say I wanted to connect all these pins together.
I can quickly take my
little lead that I have here.
I can temporarily put it right there
and then I can bend it like that
and I can actually go in and connect all these points.
Sometimes you just need a lot of points connected together.
See how quickly I can flood that?
Look at that.
Beautiful bar of solder.
So, you know, imagine I had all different breakout wires
that I want to connect on the other side.
That's a really simple way of doing it.
Wires are connected the same way.
You know, I like to use these little
flush cutters.
I just put the wire in on the front.
There's my wire on the back
and I can easily just go in there
and solder it
right where it needs to be.
Done.
A little bit of a cold solder joint
but don't worry about it.
Another very useful thing
is make sure you trim these leads down.
Get them real nice and short
and close to the board.
So that's basically how you build
on a PerfBoard.
Now, there's all different kinds.
Some of them have built-in rows.
Some of them look just like breadboards
and that's the last thing I want to show you.
I'm a big fan of these.
These are called the perma-proto boards.
And what I like about these
is if you look very carefully,
each one of these holes is connected already
just like it would be on a breadboard.
And if you're building this circuit,
I can buy a perma-proto board.
That's a half-size breadboard.
This happens to be a quarter size that I have here.
But I can literally just hold this right here
and build the same circuit,
wire it up the same way as my breadboard,
flip it over, solder it together,
and it works perfectly.
These are extremely handy.
They're quite affordable.
And to be quite honest with you,
if you're building a prototype,
they're really slick looking.
So that's about it for building on a PerfBoard.
I hope those tips and tricks help you a little bit
and ease that learning curve.